en directo a Vamos hasta Nueva York que
el gobierno local está pagando autobuses
a los migrantes que deseen trasladarse a
otras zonas del país esto ante el
elevado número de personas que son
enviadas por gobernadores de los estados
fronterizos con México hacia la gran
manzana muchos de estos migrantes han
decidido trasladarse a la frontera con
Canadá tomando por sorpresa a las
autoridades de este país para conocer
los detalles saludamos a esta hora
nuestra corresponsal en Nueva York mamen
sala mame muy buenas noches cuéntenos
Cuáles son los motivos por los que se le
están ofreciendo estas posibilidades a
los migrantes que llegan a la ciudad y
sobre todo que ha dicho al respecto el
alcalde Erick Adams
si Precisamente en eso está haciendo
muchísimo hincapié el alcalde de la
ciudad de Nueva York Eric Adams dice que
no se trata de una estrategia coordinada
entre Estados Unidos y Canadá ni mucho
menos está reenviando migrantes
indocumentados de que han llegado de
Texas y Arizona a Canadá para quitarse
de encima el problema dice que son casos
puntuales que se les está ayudando se
les está ofreciendo una boleta de
autobús gratuita y se les está ayudando
a ir a Canadá los que piden ir a Canadá
como los que están pidiendo ir a otros
estados o a otras ciudades lo cierto Es
que aquí muchos medios de comunicación
apuntan desde hace ya un par de días que
se trata de una estrategia por parte del
ayuntamiento para liberar un poco la
ciudad y frenar esa crisis migratoria en
la que se encuentra ahora mismo dicen
que han hablado con migrantes
indocumentados la mayoría son
procedentes de Venezuela que han llegado
de Texas y de Arizona en autobuses y que
les están contando que al parecer el
ayuntamiento les invita a ir a y les
ofrece estas boletas para de autobús
gratuitas diciéndoles que allí pues la
seguridad sanitaria es mucho más
accesible mucho más económica y es todo
mucho más fácil Lo cierto es que esto
coincide con unas declaraciones que
escuchábamos hace un par de semanas
cuando el alcalde Erik Adams viajaba a
la frontera para conocer de primera mano
la situación y decía que aquí en Nueva
York no cabía ningún migrante más porque
recordemos que la ciudad está obligada a
recibir a cualquier persona que venga
aquí pidiendo refugio y está obligada a
dárselo en los últimos 10 meses han
llegado cerca de
44.000 migrantes indocumentados se han
habilitado cerca de 84 hoteles para
mujeres con niños para familias y cerca
de cinco centros sociales con camas para
los hombres pero sí que es verdad que he
estado que Nueva York se encuentra
completamente saturada aquí ya no cabe
nadie más y empieza a tener un problema
y todo Una crisis de emergencia por la
situación a raíz de los migrantes
indocumentados están llegando a la
ciudad y que se suman a los miles de
personas sin hogar que ya había antes
mamen y Cuál ha sido entonces la
respuesta de las autoridades migratorias
en Canadá
si en una rueda de prensa en Monreal la
ministra de inmigración de Quebec dijo
estar muy sorprendida con la situación
que se está viviendo hizo hincapié en
que Canadá haya Estados Unidos continúan
las negociaciones para actualizar ese
tratado de Tercer país seguro que
firmaron en el 2022 y ese acuerdo tiene
algunas lagunas legales que al parecer
apuntan aquí varios activistas son las
que estaría aprovechando la alcaldía de
Nueva York para enviar a estos migrantes
indocumentados a Canadá Cuáles son Pues
bien no incluyen en este tratado la
entrada por zonas irregulares lo que
dice el tratado es que cuando una
persona entra en un país ya sea Canadá o
Estados Unidos tiene que pedir asilo en
ese primer país donde entra pero este
tratado no englobaría no tendría
incluido zonas como la de plasburg por
ejemplo que es una zona de cruce de la
frontera y regular por donde al parecer
están pasando la mayoría de estos
migrantes indocumentados desde Nueva
York entonces aquí lo que está
ocurriendo es que los activistas y
muchas personas están denunciando en
Muchos medios de comunicación están
denunciando que el alcalde de Nueva York
estaría aprovechando ese vacío legal
para enviar inmigrantes indocumentados a
través de esa de ese trozo de la
frontera en plattsburg a Canadá el
gobierno canadiense ha reaccionado justo
después de que se conociera la noticia a
partir de uno de los medios locales de
aquí ha dicho que de hecho tenía en
mente actualizar y hacer una serie de
cambios en este acuerdo sobre todo a
raíz de la llegada masiva de migrantes
indocumentados procedentes de Texas pero
de momento no ha habido cambios
significativos y estamos muy pendientes
de ver cómo evolucionan esas
actualizaciones esas negociaciones para
actualizar ese tratado tan importante